ahora resolvamos el inciso c usa el
razonamiento cuantitativo incluyendo a
ecuaciones si es necesario para
desarrollar una expresión para la nueva
posición final del bloque expresa tu
respuesta en términos de d vamos a
dibujar una tabla aquí abajo para
responder al inciso c
permíteme establecer dos argumentos el
argumento 1 en donde comprimimos el
resorte con delta x igual a d y tenemos
el argumento 2 en donde comprimimos el
resorte el doble de la distancia delta x
igual a 2 d
vamos a dibujar la tabla más o menos así
y pensemos en algunas cosas lo primero
en lo que quiero pensar es en la energía
potencial cuando comprimimos el resorte
la energía potencial cuando comprimimos
el resorte para el primer argumento le
llamamos energía potencial 11 es igual a
un medio porque la constante del resorte
multiplicada por la distancia a la que
comprimimos el resorte al cuadrado para
el argumento 2 la energía potencial u2
es igual a un medio porque la constante
del resorte por la distancia a la que
comprimimos el resorte que ahora es el
doble al cuadrado y esto es igual
un medio de camps la constante del
resorte por 4 d al cuadrado pongo el 4
hasta adelante y me queda que esto es
igual a 4 por un medio por k por d al
cuadrado que es igual a 4 por 11 es 4
veces la energía potencial de cuando
comprimimos el resorte en de aquí ya
vimos algo de lo que hablamos en la
parte ve de que si comprimimos el
resorte al doble vamos a tener 4 veces
la energía potencial pues la energía
potencial no crece proporcionalmente con
la cantidad de distancia que comprimimos
el resorte crece al cuadrado de esta
compresión ahora pensemos en la energía
cinética la energía cinética cuando x es
igual a cero justo cuando el resorte
deja de estar en contacto con el bloque
y ya no lo empuja más nuestra energía
cinética cada uno va a ser igual a lo
que era nuestra energía potencial de
cuando el resorte estaba comprimido u
otra forma de pensar en esto es que toda
la energía potencial ahora
se ha transformado en energía cinética y
que pasa en el argumento 2 k 2 la
energía cinética 2 igual que vimos
anteriormente será igual a la energía
potencial 2 d cuando el resorte estaba
comprimido el doble y después se
transformó en energía cinética y esto es
igual a 4 veces 1 que es lo mismo que 4
veces la energía cinética del argumento
1 esto es igual a 4 k 1 así que tenemos
4 veces la energía cinética 4 veces la
energía cinética y ahora con respecto a
la distancia a la que se detiene el
bloque la distancia a la que se detiene
sabemos que aquí es de 3d y aquí nos
preguntamos cuánto vale esta
interrogación 3d
pensemos un poco en esto sabemos que la
energía cinética cuando x igual a cero
cada uno más el trabajo realizado por la
fricción trabajo realizado por la
fricción que es w1 que será un trabajo
negativo porque la fuerza de fricción
actúa en sentido opuesto al movimiento
del bloque o al cambio en x así que la
energía cinética más el trabajo
realizado por la fricción será igual a
cero este trabajo cancela toda la
energía cinética una forma de pensar en
ello es que transforma todo en calor así
que pensemos en que es igual todo el
trabajo realizado por la fricción el
trabajo realizado por la fricción es
igual al coeficiente de fricción muy por
la masa del bloque por el campo
gravitacional multiplicada por la
distancia en la que está aplicándose
esta fuerza esto es la fuerza de
fricción así que la multiplicamos por
tres de iu tenemos que aclarar que esta
fuerza va en dirección contraria a la de
nuestro cambio en x y por esto vamos a
poner esta fuerza como negro
podemos decir que la energía cinética
cuando x es igual a 0 - muy que es el
coeficiente de fricción por la masa por
el campo gravitacional por 3 de va a ser
igual a cero si sumamos esto en ambos
lados nos queda acá 1 igual amor por m
por g por 3 de y si queremos despejar la
distancia dividimos ambos lados entre la
fuerza de fricción muy por m por g y nos
queda 3 de igual aquí sólo intercambió
los lados será igual a la cantidad de
energía cinética que tenemos cuando x es
igual a 0 dividida entre un eje que
podemos ver como fuerza de fricción
si queremos conocer la distancia a la
que se detiene el bloque tenemos que
encontrar la energía cinética justo
cuando x es igual a 0 cuando entramos a
la parte en donde comienza la fricción
en nuestro camino y luego la dividimos
entre la fuerza de fricción y con esto
encontramos la distancia recorrida por
el bloque hasta que se detiene así que
a distancia aquí va a ser igual a cada 2
entre la fuerza de fricción cada dos es
cuatro veces cada uno por lo que es
igual a cuatro por cada uno y nuestra
fuerza de fricción va a ser la misma
tenemos el mismo coeficiente de fricción
la misma masa y el mismo campo
gravitacional así que esto se divide
entre nuestra fuerza de fricción ya
conocemos esto la energía cinética
dividida entre la fuerza de fricción es
igual a 3 d por lo que todo esto va a
ser igual a 4 por 3 de que es igual a 12
de todo esto es la forma matemática de
decir que comprimimos el resorte al
doble y tendremos 4 veces la energía
potencial a tener comprimido el resorte
lo que significa que tendremos 4 veces
la energía cinética en x igual a 0 por
lo que tendremos 4 veces la distancia a
la que se detiene el bloque en lugar de
que el bloque se detenga en 3d o en 6 de
como proponía el estudiante ahora nos
vamos a detener
dulce de y esta es la distancia a la que
se detiene el bloque y respondimos todo
el inciso c usar razonamiento
cuantitativo incluyendo a ecuaciones si
es necesario para desarrollar una
expresión para la nueva posición final
del bloque expresa tu respuesta en
términos de de si hicimos todo esto